you have such great chemistry with
Dennis Hopper who plays your husband in
the film can you speak in he's also
another legend can you speak to us about
working with Dennis
well yes I like you very much
he just to protect me when I didn't
understood some words some things I will
ask him and you know the character she
plays afterwards after on his career
I couldn't understood that was the same
boy you know because he was like very
clean very you know like a straight he
just took out to medical school he just
to tell me and you know how I said wow
it's the same boy that place in you know
right now and we had a very good
friendship Rock Hudson of course is
another great legend that's in the film
and what were your I mean it's a very
interesting cast because obviously his
acting style was extremely different
than James Dean I'm Dennis Hopper who
were both method actors how did that all
work on the set with the various you
know in those days method and then
traditional acting was very much in
conflict what was it like on the set
with those actors well for me was like
if I was going to make an academy acting
Academy you know because I start to
learn a lot of things I was very young I
had to go to drama school but I was in
drama school what I did giant you know
and then I see the conch with James Dean
and Dennis Hopper and the different
acting of Rock Hudson and Carol Baker
that was a yes actor studio yes and
wonderful and I start to learn a lot of
things that has helped peak all over my
life and was Rock Hudson what was he
like oh he was wonderful he was a son of
the sky
he was a warm so nice you know he loved
ice cream scones and we were in Marfa
Texas it was nothing to do in that
little town there was a drugstore hyper
block from the hotel and many afternoons
me after we finished working he used to
tell me do you wanna skip gone and I
said yes so we worked together to the
drugstores to have an ice cream cone
was the only one that he didn't mind if
is God got part or no and I didn't care
I want to be near him that was all now I
know why when he orders the ice cream
for his grandson at the end of the movie
he do he does it with such gusto